ce soir et demain à la une ce soir
l'image d'une victoire et d'un record
serge madec que vous allez apercevoir
sur jet services triomphe dans la course
québec-saint-malo victoire totale car le
peloton des poursuivants et relayée à
plus de 2000 kilomètres nous y
reviendrons ambiance et commentaires à
saint malo dans quelques minutes avant
cela voici comme chaque soir les autres
temps forts de l'actualité
l'interdiction des meetings aériens en
allemagne au lendemain de la catastrophe
de rammstein le dernier bilan fait état
de 45 morts et 350 blessés
michel rocard à l'elysée quelques heures
seulement après son voyage en nouvelle
calédonie tout ce que j'ai pu faire là
bas at il dit il a été en application
des orientations définies par le
président officiel mais oui du pétrole
dans le sous sol de la capitale
elf aquitaine annonce que les résultats
du premier forage sont très
encourageants nous y reviendrons en mer
du nord peut-être la fin du cauchemar
pour les phoques plusieurs milliers
d'entre eux sont morts victimes
d'épidémie aujourd'hui les chercheurs
néerlandais aurait désolé le virus une
fête
et oui une fête qui tourne
malheureusement à la tragédie c'était
hier sur le terrain militaire de
ramstein une base américaine située à
l'ouest de la république fédérale
allemande
je vous rappelle que trois avions
appartenant à la patrouille acrobatique
italiennes se sont heurtés à une
centaine de mètres du sol
l'un d'entre eux s'est écrasé dans la
foule le dernier bilan fait état je vous
le rappel de 45 morts et de près de 350
blessés
aujourd'hui l'allemagne et l'italie
également oscille entre la consternation
et la colère
le ministre allemand de la défense a
décidé d'annuler toutes les
démonstrations d'acrobaties aériennes
il faut dire que la catastrophe a
relancé la polémique sur les vols à
basse altitude
des vols au cours desquelles certains
pilotes repousse un peu trop loin leurs
limites et celles de leurs appareils
laurent bousses y ait quelques instants
avant le drame pour effectuer un triple
croisement à basse altitude la
patrouille italienne se sépare en trois
groupes
l'avion solo allant se positionner seul
face au public une poignée de secondes
plus tard quand les deux demis
patrouille se croisent à la hauteur des
tribunes l'avion solo se dirige à plus
de 300 km heure vers la foule massée à
200 mètres de la piste erreur
d'appréciation erreur de pilotage
incident technique seule enquête pourra
le dire
toujours est il qu'hier alors que le
premier croisement avait déjà eu
sans incident l'avion solo vient heurter
de plein fouet deux appareils qui sont
immédiatement précipités au sol et leur
pilote tué sur le coup
pendant ce temps privés de ses commandes
mais entraîné par son inertie l'avion
solo devenu fou se précipite vers le
public
le drame est inévitable une chose est
sûre c'est parce que l'un des avions
évolué face à la foule que l'accident
est devenue une catastrophe c'est à
cause d'eux figure comme celle là que la
patrouille italienne n'était pas
autorisé à venir en france depuis sept
ans hier il y avait trois formations
militaires à ramstein alors les pilotes
italiens ont-ils voulu faire de la
surenchère
y at il eu sur motivation dans leur
compétition avec les autres patrouilles
ce sont de très bons pilotes mais qui
ont sûrement peu trop confiance en eux
et j'ai remarqué j'en ai fait la
réflexion en ami que leur leur
présentation est très très serré depuis
le début du siècle les meetings aériens
font partie intégrante de l'aviation il
y en a chaque année plus de 500 en
france presque tout se passe très bien
sauf quand les pilotes veulent aller au
delà de leurs limites ou de celle de
leurs machines
je vous le disais à l'instant il n'y
aura plus de démonstration aérienne en
république fédérale allemande le
ministre de la défense l'a annoncé tout
à l'heure il faut dire que dès ce matin
en allemagne
les associations les élus et la presse
dans son ensemble dénoncé je cite la
vanité entre guillemets des meetings
aériens
l'un de nos confrères écrivait même à la
une ce matin ses spectacles et alan la
fierté militaires ne sont plus de mise
aujourd'hui
regardez le sujet meeting aérien en
allemagne est ancien il ressurgit la
presse de ce lundi est largement évoqué
les appels des sociaux démocrates des
verts et de l'église
invitant à boycotter ce type de
démonstration aérienne
plus généralement les journaux allemands
rappelle la polémique sur les bosses les
vols à basse altitude après la
catastrophe d'hier leur bien-fondé mise
en cause
même quand il s'agit de redorer le
prestige de l'armée de l'air les
réactions dans les milieux politiques
ont d'ailleurs été immédiate dans un
premier temps le voit ici monsieur
rupert scholl sur le ministre de la
défense a annoncé l'annulation d'un
meeting aérien de la luftwaffe prévue
pour la fin septembre et un peu plus
tard le ministère de la défense précise
et même dans un communiqué que les
meetings aériens militaires étaient
désormais interdits en allemagne en
politique retour à paris l'image du jour
c'est celle de michel rocard à l'elysée
à peine descendu de l'avion qui le
ramenait de nouvelle calédonie le
premier ministre s'est entretenu avec le
président françois mitterrand
au menu le prochain référendum ce sera
sans doute comme convenu le 6 novembre
prochain et le succès du gouvernement
salué aujourd'hui par l'ensemble des
sondages
jean-michel mercurol rendre compte au
président dès son retour de nouméa rien
d'inhabituel pour un premier ministre
qui a su démêler une question brûlante
plus surprenant en revanche la
déclaration très officiel voulue par
michel rocard sur le perron de l'élysée
procédure encore inusité pour un premier
ministre qui a voulu partager les
mérites de son succès avec le président
de la république
mais bien de rendre compte que c'est
important voyage chez pas dire la
république gilles favard et publics dont
je voudrais rappeler que c'est grâce à
lui tout était possible puisque pendant
deux années difficiles
il a maintenu ou non de la république
française un espoir de dialogue et un
espoir d'intégrité de l'état et
qu'ensuite tout ce qui a pu se faire en
nouvelle calédonie l'a été en
application d'instruction de
d'orientation qu'il avait défini j'ai eu
plaisir à les faire et à ce que les
orientations étaient appliquées dans des
conditions qui nous laisse tous je crois
en activant satisfait du travail bien
commencé affirmer la bonne entente au
sommet de l'état chacun dans son rôle
télé le but de michel rocard qui veut
ainsi répondre à ce qu'il appelle les
bavardages d'influer sur d'éventuelles
difficultés entre lui et françois
mitterrand à propos de la nouvelle
calédonie alain juppé le secrétaire
général du rpr vient de se prononcer
contre le principe du référendum qu'il
juge inutiles et nuisibles at il dit
alain juppé qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques minutes sur les antennes de nos
confrères d'rtl affirmé que le premier
ministre devrait se contenter d'une
consultation au parlement fin de
citation politique et petites phrases
suite les états d'âme des lieutenants de
jacques chirac s'étale dans les colonnes
de certains confrères depuis quelques
jours après philippe seguin et françois
fillon pour le plus célèbre etienne
pinte député d isly des yvelines et vice
président du groupe rpr à l'assemblée
nationale affirme aujourd'hui que le rpr
a perdu son âme
fin de citation on attend maintenant la
réaction d'alain juppé le secrétaire
général du mouvement gaulliste devrait
mettre les points sur les i dans
quelques jours olivier lerner il nous
faut pas avoir fait l'ena pour
comprendre la prose détiennent 27
cheville ouvrière du rpr a pris sa plus
belle plume pour pousser dans le monde
un cri d'alarmé qui ne passera pas
inaperçu enplus le vice président du
groupe rpr à l'assemblée n'est pas un
cas isolé
après l'échec des présidentielles et des
législatives philippe seguin et françois
fillon par exemple n'ont pas pu cacher
longtemps leur vague à l'âme aujourd'hui
les séguiniste non plus pour décrire
il parlait
nous avons subi deux échecs de double
échec en 81 et en 88 et ses échecs nous
interpelle je pense que l'une des
raisons de ces échecs c'est que nous
allons peut-être trop privilégier
l'action par rapport à la réflexion et à
l'analyse
je crois que lorsqu'on a subi des échecs
c'est en partie parce qu'on a perdu son
âme c'est parce que les français ne se
reconnaissent pas majoritairement dans
un parti politique et donc ne le porte
pas au pouvoir
comme il est loin le temps où on ne
voyait qu'une seule tête derrière
jacques chirac
si le rpr perd son âme alain juppé
pourrait bien perdre son sang froid
le nouveau secrétaire général du rpr
sait qu'il devra faire face désormais à
deux courants les chiraquiens dont il
fait partie et les séguiniste deux
courants dans l'air du temps
le prochain papier pro seguin sera
signée alain devaquet en france toujours
un chiffre qui défraie la chronique pour
la première fois depuis 1979 la
croissance de l'économie atteindra 3 5%
cette année un chiffre intéressant qui
contredit ma foi certaines prévisions
plutôt alarmistes formulées depuis
quelques mois
alors non seulement le krach boursier
d'octobre 87 de triste mémoire n'a pas
freiné le bel élan de notre économie
mais la croissance s'est étendue à
l'ensemble des entreprises
détails explications d'une bonne
surprise avec claire chazal
une fois n'est pas coutume la réalité
économique sera cette année meilleur que
ce que prévoyait le budget 88
ainsi pour la croissance alors que les
experts avaient tablé sur un chiffre de
1 9%
on devrait dépasser maintenant les 3 %
les effets négatifs du krach boursier de
l'automne dernier avait visiblement été
surestimé principal moteur de la reprise
l'investissement les entreprises n'ont
pas freiné leurs projets d'équipement
bien au contraire l'investissement
productif presque entièrement
autofinancé devrait exploser et croître
de 10% cette année deux fois plus vite
que prévu petit revers de la médaille
les prix pourraient légèrement dérapé et
progressé de 3% contre une prévision
initiale de deux ans et demi pour cent
seulement mais cela dans un contexte de
reprise de l'inflation mondiale
première conséquence de l'envolée de la
croissance une reprise des créations
d'emplois plus
cinquante mille au premier semestre 88
mais qui reste insuffisante pour
renverser la courbe du chômage
second résultat l'argent devrait rentrer
à flot dans les caisses de l'état
une marge de manoeuvre d'environ 10
milliards de francs devrait ainsi
permettre au gouvernement d'alléger l'an
prochain les impôts pour les sociétés
est de baisser la tva sur life i ou
l'automobile
rien n'est tranché pour le moment une
question enfin l'avenir sera-t-il aussi
favorable les pouvoirs publics semblent
plus prudent il table sur une croissance
comprise entre deux et demi et 3 % et
sur une inflation de 2,2 pour cent pour
1989 à paris l'escroquerie au parcmètre
continue d'alimenter les conversations
et de faire la une des journaux je vous
rappelle que l'escroquerie porte sur 20
millions de francs et qu'une bonne
vingtaine de fonctionnaires de la mairie
de paris ont été inculpés ou écroué dès
aujourd'hui la ville de paris devait
faire face au problème du remplacement
des employés indélicats
c'est chose faite vingt-cinq inspecteurs
assermentés bien sûr viennent d'être
chargés de la collecte
éric perrin ses 25 fonctionnaires
assermentés de la ville de paris sont
habituellement affectés à la sécurité
des parcs et jardins
depuis ce matin ils sont chargés de
collecter et de trier l'argent des parcs
m pour cela il utilise les fameuses
aspirateur chaque horodateur à une clé
numérotés qui permet au piège de tomber
dans un coffre cadenassé et plombé le
trafic évaluées pour l'instant à 20
millions de francs se faisait en grande
partie pendant le transport vers le
centre de tri par le déplombage des
conteneurs mais les policiers chargés de
l'enquêté savent désormais que les
employés indélicats à récupérer aussi le
trop plein d'eau n'est resté dans le
tuyau de l'aspirateur ou détourné
directement les sacs de pièces triées
avant leur transfert à la banque de
france ce qui confirmerait l'hypothèse
d'une complicité de la quasi totalité du
service
il aura fallu plusieurs années pour
découvrir un trafic apparemment enfantin
les systèmes de surveillance au moment
du tri n'ont pas prouvé leur efficacité
et la ville de paris n'avait pas choisi
des appareils équipés de compteurs
option pourtant proposé par le
constructeur
demander un certain nombre de précisions
aux constructeurs qui nous avait donné
toutes garanties
il semble bien que ces garanties
n'étaient pas suffisantes et on ne peut
pas en imputer la responsabilité à la
ville je rappelle aussi que ce système
est en place dans toute la france c'est
le même système qui existe partout et
c'est la ville de paris qui a été en
avant nous étions intéressés par ce
problème puisque nous avons mis à
l'essai l'expérience dont je parle de
terminale micro micro contact qui est
très fiable qui doit permettre justement
dans l'avenir ce contrôle
les jeunes socialistes ont demandé
l'examen de cette affaire au prochain
conseil municipal
il est vrai que les sommes en jeu sont
considérables ce service rapporte chaque
année 270 millions de francs ça fait
réfléchir sur les routes au lendemain
d'un week-end particulièrement meurtrier
nous allons nous arrêter ce soir sur une
expérience exemplaire sur place
l'association réagir et un organisme qui
dépend de la sécurité routière se
propose d'étudier les circonstances des
accidents pour mieux faire face au fléau
l'image que vous allez voir je vous lis
tout de suite est dure mais elle est
exemplaire il faut savoir que pour la
première fois depuis 1986 le nombre de
morts sur les routes de france en
juillet est supérieur à 1000 à digne
dans les alpes-de-haute-provence
l'autopsié d'un accident avec isabelle
bechler j'avais pas beaucoup de temps de
réaction un peu refréné jeudi un match
énorme
nationale 85 sortie ouest de digne 3
heures du matin dimanche
trois vacanciers stéphanois sur le
chemin du retour ont été percutées par
deux jeunes de digne qui rentraient
d'une fête au cal beaucoup trop arrosée
visibilité réagir dimanche matin 10h
quatre inspecteurs départementaux de la
sécurité routière ont été alertés les
premières données sont communiqués par
la police qui a fait le constat de nuit
il reste à aller sur les lieux pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
une enquête pluridisciplinaire menée par
un pompier un gendarme un cadre de
l'équipement un usager tous volontaires
malheureusement en pleine nuit il n'y
avait aucun témoin oculaire nouveau rôle
et jeune femme nous crier de suite après
j'ai dit à mon mari je crois qu'un
accident est en visite à la femme qui
est la première balle pied d'appel est
sorti tout important de voir si la
voirie la signalisation l'éclairage
public non pas une part de
responsabilité quant aux épaves
on les retrouve à la casse pour une
véritable autopsie toujours dans un
esprit de prévention limites et même
didier terrier voilà neuf l'aiguillette
à 0 1 le compteur est bloqué une boisson
alcoolisée outre l'aspect humain avec
interrogatoires des protagonistes
il s'agit de reconstituer leur histoire
dans les heures qui ont précédé
l'accident
ce travail de fourmi cette direction
méthodique des accidents graves sont
fait partout en france but faire
progresser la réglementation orienter la
répression des délits mais surtout
préparer de nouvelles campagnes de
sensibilisation des automobilistes
c'est quasiment officiel depuis cet
après midi on a trouvé mais oui du
pétrole dans le sous sol de la région
parisienne les responsables d'elf
aquitaine évoque des résultats
encourageants sans plus
le pétrole se trouverait à plus de 2000
mètres de profondeur reste à savoir bien
sûr si les prochains forages vont
confirmer l'information
patrick espère ne foutent
c'était il y a trois semaines
de la boue qui gicle il ne s'agissait
pas encore de pétrole mais d'eau
injectées dans le forage pour lubrifier
le trépan qui commence et à mordre le
sous sol parisien
depuis cette date à raison d'une
centaine de mètres par jour
l'outil a atteint une profondeur de 2000
mètres mieux le forage effectué en
janvier a permis d'atteindre l'endroit
exact où les géologues pensait avoir
localisé le pétrole le trépan est passé
sous la scène et a effectivement permis
d'extraire ce matin 25 baril de pétrole
juste en dessous d'un groupe d'immeubles
à 300 mètres seulement du boulevard
périphérique 4 mètres cubes de brut
qualité parisienne qu'il va falloir
maintenant analyser pour déterminer si
la découverte un intérêt économique ces
quatre mètres cubes ce ne sont qu'un
premier une première production qui nous
est nécessaire pour apprécier ce à quoi
nous avons affaire mais il nous faut
poursuivre le forage et les prises
d'échantillons de terrain en carottages
verticale pour connaître l'épaisseur
réelle de ce gisement six gisements il y
a nous le saurons dans dix jours
est-ce qui éventuellement on peut penser
qu'elle du pétrole en dessous tout paris
est ce que vous ferez placées à concorde
on peut rêver bien sûr il valide équidés
pétrole sous la place de la concorde
vous ne verrez jamais un derrick place
de la concorde
peut-être dans un endroit voisins et
nous irions en déviation sous la place
de la concorde mais c'est vraiment du
rêve effectué pour le compte de l ce
total et d'épée ce forage a coûté un
milliard de centimes
si tout se passe bien son exploitation
pourrait peut-être fournir 100 mètres
cubes par jour c'est-à-dire 600 barils
je vous le disais dès le début de
l'aventuré paris texas peut-être mais on
est très loin des productions
vertigineuse de l'ignoble jr
patrick c'est dallas là vous avez les
pièces à conviction dans le jeu est une
pièce à conviction là j'ai un morceau de
la carotte a été remonté du fond à peu
près à 2000 mètres de profondeur la
carotte en fait c'est la roche poreuse
qui contient le pétrole donc le pétrole
swann de cette roche quand on la remonte
alors quand le trou et forêts et bien à
l'intérieur du trou le pétrole va
s'écouler doucement puis va remonter à
la surface grâce à la pression et comme
je recule absolument devant aucun
sacrifice est pétrole devant aucun
risque je vous en servir un verre ça
c'est du grand prix forage d'ivry 88
s'en souviendraient voilà
danser c'est un peu efféminé et p1 c'est
un peu et emilie pétrole brut quand même
si brut de brut de paris il fleure bon
la est ce qu'il est aussi efficace que
le pétrole d'arabie saoudite par exemple
je suis pas spécialiste mais je vous
pose la quasi les chambres et je sais
pas si c'est noël une du pétrole mais il
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils soient pas
aussi efficace celui d'arabie séoudite
en tout cas on sera dans les jours qui
viennent puisque on procède actuellement
aux analyses pour savoir la fois quelle
quantité il y a si ça vaut la peine de
l'extraire à combien de mètres cubes
pour que ce soit rentable là on peut
dire qu'à partir de quelques dizaines de
mètres cubes par jour ça vaudra la peine
alors je crois savoir que les
responsables espèrent atteindre une
centaine de mètres cubes par jour
mais il s'en défend le faire si patrick
nous tenons au courant ou tard en
fourrant merci on va voir rapidement les
autres télégramme d'actualité avec
dominique verdeilhan bon niveau
collision entre deux trains express en
autriche premier bilan 5 morts et 44
blessés dont certains très grièvement la
catastrophe a eu lieu en gare de vols
furent à 480 km à l'ouest de vienne
plusieurs wagons ont déraillé selon les
premières informations il s'agirait
d'une erreur d'aiguillage l'un des deux
trains circulaient sur une voie qui ne
lui était pas destiné
il s'appelle abdallah dan mamane il est
le premier cosmonaute de kaboul à faire
partie de l'équipage soviéto afghan qui
a quitté baïkonour à bord du vaisseau
soyouz dm6 cette expédition intervient
au moment où l'urss estime nécessaire la
poursuite des relations économiques avec
kaboul après le retrait des troupes
soviétiques les trois hommes rejoindront
dans deux jours la station orbitale mir
ou deux autres cosmonautes s'apprête à
battre le record de présence dans les
sparks climat tendu à genève dans les
négociations de paix entre l'iran et
l'irak le ministre irakien des affaires
étrangères monsieur tarek aziz a déclaré
que le statut du cheval arabe fleuve
intérieur pour l'irak voies d'eaux
internationales pour l'iran constituait
le principal point de litige entre
bagdad et téhéran
une controverse qui ne semblent pas
affectés pour le moment la poursuite des
négociations le ministre irakien ayant
déclaré qu'il était prêt à rester à
genève aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
image de symbolique la destruction de
trois ss20 d'une portée de 5 mille
kilomètres cela porte à treize le nombre
de missiles détruits par les soviétiques
conformément à l'accord soviéto
américain sur l'élimination des engins
nucléaires
une destruction qui s'est effectuée en
présence du général américain roland la
joie chef des inspecteurs envoyé en urss
par les usa pour surveiller
l'application de l'accord de juin
dernier dans le département du calvados
delphine demeure introuvable delphine
c'est cette petite fille de 10 ans qui a
disparu samedi alors qu'elle participe
et très simplement un camp de scouts à
villerville une petite station balnéaire
de normandie
aucun élément nouveau n'est intervenu
aujourd'hui en dépit du ratissage qui
mobilise plus de 300 personnes
les photos de delphine placardées dans
toute la région n'ont suscité aucune
réaction nouvelle agnès poirier tout
autour de villerville on a placardé sa
photo delphine 10 ans disparu depuis
trois jours plus de 300 gendarmes
soldats pompiers ratissent la région
chaque puits chaque blockhaus chaque
maison abandonnée a été fouillée sans
résultant les chiens perdre la piste de
la fillette
tout près de cette ferme un kilomètre du
campement fugue enlèvement les parents
delphine ne comprennent pas bon allez il
est tranquille et réservé bon allez
costaud c'est une fille qui est assez
grande qui résistante donc penser que ça
dérange pas de marcher longtemps
par contre est réservé les timides 12
enfants
deauville et trouville ont été
quadrillés une commerçante affirme avoir
vu la petite fille samedi devant la
caisse d'epargne une autre femme dit
avoir reçu hier un étrange coup de
téléphone je m'appelle delphine je suis
seul et je suis perdue lui aurait dit
une fillette avant de raccrocher
delphine pensent les enquêteurs n'est
peut-être s'est peut-être égarée en
voulant récupérer le fanion de son
équipe perdu la veille
trop timides elles n'ose se manifester
une hypothèse parmi tant d'autres peut
être la fin d'un cauchemar pour les
phoques de la mer du nord dont on a
beaucoup parlé je vous rappelle qu'une
épidémie a causé la mort de plusieurs
milliers d'entre eux apparemment les
phoques était victime de pneumonie et
surtout d'infection du foie et bien ce
soir
l'espoir renaît car des scientifiques
néerlandais viennent de déterminer les
causes de cette hécatombe l'épidémie
seraient dus au virus de la maladie de
carré une
dick qui touche habituellement les
jeunes chiens chaque doigt le virus
tueur de phoque est identifié a annoncé
aujourd'hui les nids art directrice de
l'hôpital des phoques de peterborough ce
virus qui a tué neuf mille phoques de la
mer du nord et de la baltique serait
apparentée à la maladie de carré une
affection qui touche habituellement les
jeunes chiens ce virus affaiblit le
système immunitaire des animaux en
provoquant des to et les infections de
la peau
l'épidémie a probablement démarré à la
suite de contacts entre les phoques et
les chiens au danemark à peter buren les
virologues ont expérimenté sans succès
plusieurs vaccins six mois de recherche
avec l'institut néerlandais de la santé
publique ont permis d'isoler le
mystérieux virus
en prélevant du sang sur les animaux
soigné à l'hôpital
on a constaté la présence d'anticorps
contre la maladie et en même temps
l'apparition de symptômes de cette
affection
si la pollution de la mer du nord de la
baltique n'est pas la cause directe du
phénomène
elle l'a certainement aggravé un vaccin
existe bien contre la maladie de carré
mais comment l'appliquer aux milliers de
phoques sein qui sont presque
impossibles à capturer au milieu de
l'océan la voile à présent victoires et
records pour jet services dans québec
saint malo le catamaran de serge madec a
franchi la ligne d'arrivée tout à
l'heure aux alentours de 17h madec et
ses équipiers bat par la même occasion
le record établi par fax caradec
il y a quatre ans seulement l'exploit
commentait par claude ai marre
superbe victoire pour jet services de
grands catamarans de serge madec
remporte cette deuxième édition de la
transat québec saint malo victoires et
records les concurrents sont partis
dimanche 21 août à 19h30 jet services
est arrivé cet après midi à 17h 05 soit
effectuant la traversée en sept jours
21h34 avec une moyenne de 15 noeuds 24 g
de services améliore le record de
l'épreuve de pratiquement un jour un
excellent départ et surtout une course
sans problème serge madec et ses six co
équipier termine avec plus de 1000
milles
c'est à dire 1850 km d'avancé sur le
second qui devrait être birch ou perron
il pour le savoir il faudra attendre
encore trois jours
serge madec bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous en direct de saint malo bonsoir et
bravo expliquez moi comment vous avez
fait pour distancer aussi magistralement
les autres concurrents de québec saint
malo
je crois que c'était une traversée bon
qui peut savoir en tg1 10000 mètres à
part que nous on a commencé par le
sprint on est parti
à fond la caisse comme on dit en
manoeuvrant sans arrêt dans le saint
laurent qui était pour nous la clé de la
course et on s'est détaché à ce moment
là et après la situation météo nous
avons autorisé
plus on était vers les côtes européennes
plus on avait du vent favorable et elles
sont là on a creusé jour après jour les
quarts oui alors vous faites forme je
suis tenté de dire que vous avez de la
chance c'est comme tous les grands
champions
ils ont tous rencontré des baleines
nains j'écoutais myburgh vous n'en
n'avez pas vu vous y apposer décision on
en a vu plusieurs on a même
earth est assez violemment deux requins
pèlerins des des poissons qu'ils font à
peu près six mètres de long mais sans
dommage pour le bateau et on a failli on
a failli percuter une baleine à peu près
la longueur du bateau des c'est-à-dire
de 25 mètres de long mais on a réussi à
l'éviter effectivement il faut toujours
un peu de chance pour réussir ce soir
physiquement vous êtes bien là vous nous
présentez vos équipiers ça a l'air
d'aller là vous avez tous le sourire on
le comprend car moralement tout est
intact
on n'a pas très chaud et on a faim je
crois qu'on va pas tarder à les manger
mais on va on va récupérer on a on n'a
pas dormi pendant une semaine mais je
crois que en deux trois jours
tout le monde sera d'aplomb ouais ça ne
vous gêne pas d'avoir gagné là
pratiquement sans concurrence parce
qu'ils sont loin derrière les autres
ils sont à ils sont à combien elle à
près de 2000 km ben ils étaient près de
nous au départ de québec
c'est après que ça a été plus dur pour
eux mais bon c'est sûr là le phénomène
météo nous a avantagés mais disons qu'il
fallait qu'ils s'accrochent au départ
c'est là qu'on a gagné la course
maintenant on va les attendre vous
répondez à ceux qui dit il sont pas tous
gentils avec vous un bastia qui sont
mauvais perdant ils disent bon bah il a
gagné enfin ils ont gagné parce qu'il
avait le meilleur bateau qu'il avait les
équipiers de luxe avec lui 1 il n'avait
pas pris n'importe qui avant de partir
ben c'est sûr on a le meilleur bateau on
a le meilleur équipage on gagne je vois
pas où est le scandale
haye a pas de scandale à nous on vous
félicite mais il y en a qui formulent ce
genre de réflexion vous les entendrez
102,6 les catamarans été admis à courir
la coupe de l'america est ce que les
preuves vous tenterait serge madec c'est
une question de spécialistes qu'on vient
de me tendre la l'instant
là on a failli un moment donné
s'inscrire un pur pour là pour
participer
là actuellement le navire américain
sound strike est un catamaran et je
pense que il va il va mettre minable le
le néo zélandais qui est un monocoque
merci on vous laisse faire la fête vous
serez là pour attendre ceux qui suivent
derrière un peu plus loin
bah si j'arrive le mois prochain un plat
de pommes et oui on va les attendre deux
trois jours merci à vous et bonne soirée
et merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et je vous laisse rentrer à la maison
parce qu'il a pas l'air de faire chaud
voilà donc quelques instants les
prévisions météo avec josé blanc
lapierre vers minuit dernier journal
présenté par aubry et de l'air demain
n'oubliez surtout pas vous rendez vous
habituel 6h45 télématin 7h45 roland
leroy sera l'invité des 4 vérités de
gérard morin 13h l'édition de la mi
journée où vous retrouverez patricia
charnolé william leymergie mais où ils
sont rentrés depuis aujourd'hui à demain
20h merci de votre fidélité excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 bien sûr bonsoir
oh